so this must be one of the rarest
vehicles in the world this is a VBIED
vehicle born improvised explosive device
a suicide bombers truck captured before
it could detonate it's been incredibly
carefully built these wire protection
structures they may look faintly
ridiculous like something you might find
in a garden center fact they are almost
100 percent effective against
rocket-propelled grenades going head-on
this would have been very hard to stop
with a standard infantry weapon all of
this is homemade armor it's been welded
on again to allow the vehicle to get
through even the engine is inside an
armored block and again you have what's
called this bar armor to protect the
driver with a very small bulletproof
windscreen there the whole idea of this
is not to keep the driver alive
indefinitely but long enough to get
absolutely close to its final target so
that so that so that the their enemies
can be destroyed now these have been put
to absolutely devastating ends now here
we've got some Peshmerga who are
enjoying experiencing life behind their
even starting the engine for us this is
the very seat where a suicide bomber
would have driven to his death trying to
take as many Peshmerga fighters with
them as they can this is a standard
suburban vehicle that has been turned
into one of the most fearsome weapons in
this war of improvisation now let's take
a look at what goes on in the back cab
again another armoured structure here to
prevent anybody shooting the driver from
behind very carefully thought through
quite skillfully put together quite
honestly a pretty frightening notion now
packed into this and protected again by
yet more armor against premature
detonation even the wheels even the
wheel hubs have got covers over them the
whole idea is that this vehicle mustn't
be stopped until it can be finally
stopped in a devastating
and in the back of this the pesh MERGA
found 25 jerry cans packed with what
they call tnt it's actually plastic
explosive that be enough to destroy a
couple of tanks at the very least an
absolutely ferocious weapon and one
mercifully and very rarely was able to
survive and be captured this is not only
a kind of result as far as the Peshmerga
are concerned it's also an incredibly
important intelligence tool by
deconstructing how this was put together
they can better figure out how to
destroy it